alors je suis heureuse mais c'est hyper
compliqué parce que il y a le bon côté
des choses mais il y a aussi le mauvais
côté ça fait plusieurs fois que j'ai
subi des agressions à Marseille on m'a
braqué à Marseille
de cambriolage un braquage et
là on a essayé de mettre le feu chez moi
alors on a les images de ça regardez
quatre chiffres de cambriolage hier
pendant mon anniversaire pendant qu'il y
avait des gens chez moi on a essayé de
me cambrioler alors que j'ai plusieurs
alarmes j'ai l'alarme de la maison j'ai
l'alarme du jardin et j'ai l'alarme de
l'extérieur sauf que j'ai fait une
erreur l'alarme de l'extérieur elle a
sonné en plus sauf que moi comme il y
avait du monde j'ai pas compris je je
l'ai désactivé pour ça je ferai très
attention
alors ça c'était alors Maëva on va
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé et après
on va tenir parce que c'est vrai que tu
dis à des bons côtés des mauvais côtés
mais c'est vrai que c'est aussi c'est
toi qui a choisi aussi de montrer ta vie
tout ça donc tu sais que voilà tu es
devenu quand on est devenu une star
c'est vrai que tout le monde te
reconnais tout le monde te connaît même
Jordan Bardella tu vois non mais c'est
vrai même le monsieur le président du
Rassemblement national
non je pense qu'il y a plus de bons
côtés mais les mauvais côtés ils sont
durs
si même quand on fait des métiers
l'image c'est vrai que regarde Raymond
regarde tu vois dans des dépression je
crois que ça se lit sur son visage tu
vois Daniel Moreau a pris 25 ans 2 ans
non mais voilà Benjamin Castaldi on en
parle pas alors déjà raconte-nous ce qui
s'est passé Maéva parce que ça c'est
vrai que ça a été un truc de fou on va
avoir les images tout à l'heure alors en
fait c'était l'anniversaire de ma mère
et on est sorti Dino resto et après on
est parti boire un verre et là il y a il
y a le service d'alarme qui m'a
téléphoné en me disant qu'il y avait des
gens à la maison donc moi
je me suis affolée donc je suis
directement rentrée chez moi ensuite il
y a le voix mon voisin qui m'a téléphoné
en me disant que il y avait le feu chez
moi qui l'avait appelé les pompiers et
en fait au moment où enfin quand j'étais
sur la route
il y avait des vidéos qui circulait ou
les gens qui ont fait ça ils vont filmer
ils ont fait tourner ça sur les réseaux
sociaux il m'a insulté et ensuite j'ai
compris que en fait on est venu
m'agresser chez moi enfin mec le feu
chez moi quoi
et ce sont des gens alors on va voir la
vidéo qui sont mis derrière regardez
le feu chez moi ils font tourner la
vidéo sur sur les réseaux sociaux et
c'est normal tout ça parce que tu es
connu
comment comment
tu as réagi ta maman elle a réagit quand
ta maman parce que c'est vrai que ta
maman on la voit beaucoup aussi sur des
vidéos est-ce qu'à un moment elle est en
train de
moi je craque j'ai passé une canne
enfermé chez moi j'ai quand je suis à
Marseille j'ai peur de sortir parce que
ben j'ai peur qu'on m'agresse quand je
suis en france je prends de la sécurité
et moi je me vois pas enfin sortir de
chez moi avec plein de garde du corps je
suis pas une star américaine mais en
fait j'ai pas le choix parce que parce
qu'on s'est agressé parce qu'on se fait
cambrioler on se fait insulter dans la
rue non que sur les réseaux sociaux
d'accord
ils étaient tellement passé de choses
chez moi que que j'ai peur et quand je
suis en france je me sens pas en
sécurité alors que à Dubaï
c'est totalement différent à Dubaï il y
a il y a pas d'alarme chez moi je dors
les fenêtres ouvertes je dors la porte
ouverte mes clés de voiture elles sont
dans la voiture je les rentre même pas à
la maison et en France je fais attention
à tout quand je suis chez moi je mets je
mets l'alarme partout je m'enferme à
double tour je ferme tous les tous les
stores de la maison parce que ce que
j'ai peur qu'on rentre chez moi
alors est-ce qu'il y a eu un quels ont
été les dégâts déjà chez toi
mais là il y a eu un mur qui a brûlé ah
ouais les en fait le voisin il a tous vu
ce qui était en train de se passer il a
tout de suite appelé les pompiers et ils
ont vite éteint le feu mais ils ont mis
ils ont mis du feu tout autour de ma
maison donc si les pompiers ils étaient
pas intervenus aussi rapidement ben ma
maison elle aurait pu prendre feu elle
aurait pu avoir des gens chez moi et
ça aurait pu ça aurait pu très mal finir
alors c'est pas du tout un cambriolage
c'était juste non là c'était pas un
cambriolage
contre moi
alors est-ce que tu sais qui qui se
cache derrière tout ça parce que les
mecs ont posté derrière c'est incroyable
alors je sais pas je suis pas sûr
maintenant j'ai des doutes ça fait
quelques mois que je me fais menacer sur
les réseaux sociaux et là c'est vrai que
ces derniers temps vendredi j'ai reçu on
m'a menacé et le lendemain il s'est
passé ça donc donc je sais pas si c'est
cette personne mais la veille on m'a dit
qu'on allait qu'on allait me tuer
là après ça ma petite cousine elle a
reçu des messages de des messages de
menaces ils ont menacé de lui faire un
truc à son salon d'esthétique donc elle
ferme carrément son salon desséchés par
rapport à ça et là il commence à prendre
ma famille carrément sur les réseaux
Maëva on reçoit tous des menaces
entre les réseaux et la vie mais là
c'est c'est dans ma vie là
je te centrer triste
à cause de moi parce que tu l'as mise
dans tes vidéos aussi oui tu regrettes
ça
regrette d'avoir mis sa mère dans une
vidéo
je regrette avec tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ouais
ce qu'il a fait
aucun commentaire
tu regrettes toi parce que ta mère tu la
vois elle en peut plus
c'est grâce à moi aujourd'hui que ma
cousine Salma elle est un peu connue sur
les réseaux sociaux et aujourd'hui à
cause de ça elle reçoit des menaces elle
est obligée de fermer son salon
aujourd'hui elle n'a pas été travaillé
et je lui écris des messages elle m'a
dit je veux j'arrête ce salon et ta mère
est-ce qu'elle t'a dit d'arrêter un
moment
après j'ai pas envie d'arrêter parce que
c'est mon travail j'aime mon travail moi
ma vie oui je gagne bien ma vie oui
donc
elle t'a dit si ça me touche trop bien
sûr qu'elle sera pas contre que j'arrête
bien la question d'arrêter oui c'est
vrai quand ça
quand tu m'as arrivé
le soir même tu t'es dit je vais arrêter
ouais il y a eu des moments où je me
suis dit en fait j'en ai marre je vais
arrêter les réseaux sociaux
après derrière
mon travail c'est que j'aime ça j'aime
partager avec ma communauté il y a un
truc aussi c'est ça aussi c'est vrai que
tu as tu gagnes bien ta vie tu as un
train de vie est-ce que c'est pas aussi
le fait que après forcément ça il faut
changer toute sa vie quoi en fait c'est
toute sa vie toute sa manière de vivre
qu'il faut changer quoi en fait le truc
c'est que les gens ils pensent qu'on est
parti vivre à Dubaï par rapport aux
impôts moi je paye toujours des impôts
en France
et en fait c'est plus pour la sécurité
parce que en France en fait toutes les
personnes connues elles vivent pas en
sécurité on se fait cambrioler on se
fait braquer alors qu'à Dubaï ça
n'existe pas à Dubaï je l'apport de chez
moi je ne l'ai jamais fermé à clé et je
dors la fenêtre ouverte alors tu avais
évidemment comme tu as dit tu as réagi à
chaud sur les réseaux parce que tu
partages tout au quotidien j'étais un
peu bourré aussi ah d'accord ok ben
c'est important le signaler
non mais c'est important
bon allez à l'anniversaire de ma mère
aussi je t'ai bourré euh non mais
regardez les images de vidéos de
surveillance de David
o il faut que j'appelle le centre il va
me les envoyer
ils sont rentrés dans ma maison frère
elles sont rentrés donc ils sont rentrés
chez toi
donc c'est quand même une histoire de
fouillis Guillaume non là vous êtes
évidemment une victime dans cette
histoire on peut souhaiter à personne de
vivre ça mais qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui disent que vous
montrez trop justement votre vie privée
et aussi toute cette opulence qui peut
être prise par certains comme de la
provocation sur les réseaux sociaux non
mais en fait c'est notre vie de montrer
en fait moi j'ai talent un chanteur son
talent c'est de chanter donc il est
suivi par des millions de personnes
parce que parce qu'il a un talent moins
j'en ai pas moi les gens ils me suivent
parce que ils aiment ma personnalité et
qu'ils aiment ma vie donc je suis obligé
de de montrer ma vie alors mon travail
de montrer ma vie française
et puis quand je suis en france je mets
pas de bijoux à Marseille surtout je
mets pas de montre il y a beaucoup il y
a beaucoup de gens qui disent non
attendez 2 minutes on va venir Cédric
qui disent ce qui fait agir c'est que tu
te sentes plus bien en France alors que
ce qui a des gens qui disent c'est la
France qui t'a donné qui t'a fait ce que
tu es aujourd'hui j'aime la France et
j'aime venir en France et je vais
revenir en France mais en fait en France
je me sens pas en sécurité et la preuve
regardez ce qui m'a tout ce qui m'arrive
on vient mettre le feu tu payes tes
impôts là-bas et en plus donc pourquoi
les gens de non mais je paye toujours
mes impôts en France
décidé d'une fille qui se fait violer
elle porte une petite trop courte elle a
le droit de gagner de l'argent elle a le
droit de le montrer elle aurait montré
en or elle peut faire ce qu'elle veut
encore une fois elle l'a pas volé on
peut pas lui reprocher
Mathieu sur le fait que des gens
rentrent de chez elle brûle sa maison
euh l'insulte et tout ça ça vraiment
c'est inadmissible on en convient et le
harcel et cetera après quand tu fais un
métier d'image tout sur tout le reste
les insultes sur les réseaux tout ça
mais aussi on en a tous Voilà et ça
c'est le jeu un moment si tu veux pas te
faire insulter sur les réseaux si tu
veux que y ait que des gens qui disent
bah tu es parfait tu es magnifique tu as
une belle barbe Cyril et ce soir
mais c'est ça ça c'est normal
pas tout le monde peut m'aimer faire là
c'est très grave
bien sûr
savoir ce que vont avoir les mecs là
parce que ça pour moi c'est
grave bah je pense qu'ils vont les
retrouver ben moi déjà quand on m'a
braqué c'est le policier carrément qui a
qui a qui a donné le scoop à un blogueur
donc maintenant en France même les
policiers ils parlent avec des blogueurs
non mais pour répondre à Mathieu je
pense qu'il y a une petite nuance entre
cautionner et perte personne ne
cautionne ça des incendies des
agressions évidemment on souhaite ça à
personne et s'interroger sur le fait
quand on a beaucoup d'argent et tant
mieux pour vous mais de le montrer
systématiquement de donner non mais vous
gagnez vous gagnez beaucoup d'argent
quand même ben je gagne bien mal
maintenant on gagne plus notre vie comme
avant ouais mais c'est beaucoup quand
même tu gagnes combien même maintenant
c'est c'est énorme
non mais on peut gagner beaucoup
d'argent et le garder pour soi et pas
forcément de le montrer partout et
exhiber ce qu'on adresse
on peut s'interroger là-dessus c'est pas
cautionner les incendies arrête de faire
le parallèle horrible avec le viol enfin
c'est c'est ignoble de faire ça on peut
se demander si aujourd'hui quand on est
très jeune et qu'on gagne beaucoup
d'argent oui ça soucie déjà dit oui vous
savez que vous exaspérez énormément de
gens parce que c'est bien de montrer et
c'est normal de se faire
braquer parce que donc en fait
qu'on va de sécurité tu as pas
le droit elle a pas le droit de montrer
que tu as réussi dans ta vie donc on a
pas le droit pourquoi
pas mettre un policier derrière chaque
citoyen
est-ce que montrer qu'on a réussi dans
la vie c'est Snapper des montres en
diamant toute la journée et des des
villas en particulier mais vous savez
qui vous faites ça enfin en général les
enfants vous faites ça bah sinon mais
peu importe
il y a des vidéos Maëva le monde des
fringues de luxe tout ça mais ça c'est
ton métier c'est ça c'est mon travail de
montrer ma vie alors oui mais après donc
c'est normal comme tu dis que tu te
fasses insulter que tu te fasses sauter
des gens aiment moi voilà exactement je
me suis pas faite cambrioler parce que
la France j'ai pas de j'ai pas mes sacs
de luxe qui sont restés à Dubaï parce
que je suis tombé
ici
vous savez qu'elle était pas là qu'ils
ont dû voir qu'elle était pas là ils ont
mis le feu chez elle j'aurais pu mourir
non mais il aurait pu avoir quelqu'un
chez moi et ça aurait pu très mal se
finir
est-ce que vous avez une idée est-ce que
c'est pour vous intimider vous savez que
dans au milieu de la téléréalité il y a
beaucoup de chantages il y a beaucoup de
gens qui veulent faire payer
est-ce que par hasard vous auriez déjà
reçu des menaces à ce niveau là est-ce
que ça pourrait être à ça il y aura déjà
depuis mai je me fais terminer sur les
réseaux sociaux
et
oui ces derniers temps j'ai reçu des
menaces on a on a même menacé ma famille
de quel type les menaces c'était pour
vous faire payer de menaces de mort
est-ce qu'on vous a comme ce que veut
dire Gilles est-ce qu'on essaye de
storquer de l'argent
non non jamais non jamais essayé de vous
intimider de d'essayer de vous
alors il y a des gens sur les réseaux
qui disent guillaume est de mauvaise foi
il est tous les jours habillé en Marc à
3000 euros la veste 1000 euros les
stickers
et montrer ça en permanence sur les
réseaux de manière voilà
c'est de courir après un ballon moi
c'est de montrer ma vie
il y a des gens qui le vivent très mal
qui se disent voilà mais parce que c'est
parce que c'est pas évident pour tout le
monde que quand on passe ses journées à
faire des snaps on gagne 100000 € par
mois c'est tout et qu'il y a des gens
que ça énerve est-ce que de me voler une
petite nuance je dis pas que c'est bien
de chez vous pas du tout c'est c'est
très mal de faire ça je dis juste qu'il
y a une petite question là-dessus est-ce
que c'est bien d'afficher en permanence
sa richesse de manière ostentatoire
comme ça est-ce que c'est bien de le
faire ou pas je sais pas en permanence
notre richesse tu es sur les réseaux
sociaux toi ben moi j'ai déjà vu vos
comptes non
non tu as pas fait exprès
cher voilà
la mie Kiabi là ça c'est vrai que c'est
j'avoue pour le coup Guillaume tt autour
de la table qui est mal placé on est
tous en arabe et tous les soirs à porte
manteau à 10000 balles et tu viens nous
le problème c'est pas c'est pas
d'acheter des des vêtements ou des
voitures de luxe le problème c'est de ne
pas l'antenne porte-les dans la vie et
pas à l'antenne quand les gens te vois
c'est de ne vivre qu'à travers ça de
dire regardez j'habite là regardez je
suis là regardez un peu les comptes et
je vise pas Maëva en particulier mais
regardez les comptes de toutes ces
personnes là
même chose
les Gucci les trucs etc mais des trucs
au lieu de montrer en permanence moi
toi tu détestes tes influenceurs et tu
les juges mais là c'est pas le débat
d'aujourd'hui
non il y a pas il y a pas que l'argent
facile il y a pas que rien faire il y a
aussi des gens qui s'épanouissent dans
leur travail qui font heureusement qu'il
faut autre chose qu'un financier
ça pose quand même question il y a plein
de gens qui se disent les influenceurs
montrent trop leur train de vie les gens
et notamment Maeva est aussi et aussi
trop de détails ils vont montrer votre
adresse vous montrer où vous habitez
vous montrer les gens de votre famille
alors évidemment je dois faire quoi
alors je dois m'enfermer dans une caisse
blanche et me Snapper que dans une pièce
blanche vous connaissez vivons heureux
ils vont cacher oui mais moi c'est mon
travail de montrer ma vie
ta maman tout ça parce que aujourd'hui
d'être influenceur en France ça peut
être dangereux je suis pas la seule
influenceuse avoir eu des problèmes à
cette fait braquer à
il y a eu des cambriolages quand on est
exposé ben c'est c'est les risques qu'il
y a à prendre et sauf que ça en devient
très dangereux
c'était la tentation entre guillemets du
crime organisé ou des voleurs ou de gens
qui moi je soutiens les questions de
Guillaume parce que en vous exposant
comme ça je suis désolé vous prenez des
risques de mon point de vue inconsidérer
c'est responsable pardon mais pourquoi
Dubaï il se passe
à Dubaï non non non pas de ça à Dubaï
vous vivez dans un environnement hyper
privilégié entre influenceurs dans des
endroits de luxe non non mais ça c'est
pas vrai
aujourd'hui est une si potentiel et doit
quitter la France ou dois aller à Duba
sécurité
la violence la délinquance on
s'engagement l'insécurité en disant
excuse-moi Maeva tu avais qu'à bien te
tenir ou alors je commence
très fier d'avoir d'avoir réussi et je
suis fier de montrer que que j'ai réussi
dans ma vie est fier de toi oui vraiment
ouais elle fait quoi ta maman elle a
arrêté de travailler d'accord bon parce
que c'est tu as travaillé avec toi
maintenant
donc tu étais heureuse avec elle je suis
très heureuse avec elle la famille ils
sont fier de toi alors il y a des gens
qui me disent que c'est vrai que il y en
a beaucoup d'influenceurs qui sont
partis Dubaï aussi parce que comme
disait Gilles à Marseille il y avait
voilà c'était compliqué pour eux
il y a du raquettes comme pour les
joueurs de foot à Marseille il y a un
environnement qui pour les gens fortunés
connus célèbres
identifié parce qu'on connaît vos
adresses et perturbant c'est ça que je
voulais dire c'est qu'il y a des risques
et vous le savez hélas et je pense que
si je vous ai à Paris ça serait ça
serait pas passé de la même façon parce
qu'à Paris il y a plus de sécurité je
pense mais il combattre les risques il
faut pas combattre Maëva pour combattre
l'Institut
de façon Gilles Verdez c'est un mec il y
a une meuf qui vient elle lui dit on a
brûlé chez moi il va dire ouais mais
c'est attention parce que c'est pour moi
c'était une fusée
on marche sur la tête on part d'une
jeune fille non mais de rien qui avait
pas d'argent et tout ça qui réussit on
devrait dire bravo tu as réussi ma
chérie et non lui tombe dessus une fois
de plus on avance des conséquences et
les causes et on est en train de tomber
dessus à elle alors que c'est elle les
victimes c'est fascinant ce pays Maëva
elle est victime hein qu'est-ce que tu
as à dire ce soir voilà dis-nous ce que
tu auras à dire à tous les gens qui te
harcèle et et ceux qui t'ont fait ça
j'aimerais qu'il comprenne que que oui
on est des personnes connues mais avant
d'être nous on les êtres humains et
qu'en fait on souffre de tout ce que tu
on souffre de cette situation oui on est
pas bien moi moi j'étais chez moi à
Marseille j'étais stressée et j'aimerais
trop que ça s'arrête alors je veux bien
je veux bien que parce que je suis connu
qui est des gens qui m'aiment pas
à m'agresser chez moi à mettre le feu
chez moi alors que ça aurait pu très mal
finir bah c'est pas normal de vivre ça
en France moi en France j'aime la France
et mon pays je reviendrai et il y a
toute ma famille qui est là et c'est la
France qui a fait ce que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que tu es
aujourd'hui
en sécurité là oui parce que j'ai reçu
des menaces maintenant toutes les
menaces que tu reçois tu les tu te dis
c'est avec un policier je lui envoie
tout
ce qu'ils t'ont dit les policiers
ils ont mis des des brigades autour de
chez moi et je leur numéro perso et
police
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas eu le numéro perso apprenez à
regarder l'horaire si vous voulez 10
fois en réalité
merci Maëva alors ce que je peux te
souhaiter
plein de belles choses
et de la sécurité
en tout cas et c'est vrai que voilà on
peut penser ce qu'on veut mais c'est
vrai que le
feu à une maison là ça commence à
devenir ça dépasse les bornes là on
passe dans un autre délire